the president of the european commission
has said a united europe will prevail
over russian president vladimir putin in
her annual state of the union address to
the european parliament ursula fond
alliance said europe had shown courage
and strength following russia's invasion
of ukraine that much was at stake not
just for ukraine but also for europe and
the world the commission president said
russia's war on ukraine was also a war
on europe's economy and its values
much is at stake
not just for ukraine
but for all of europe and the world at
large
and we will be tested
tested by those
who want to exploit any kind of division
between us
and this is not only a war unleashed by
russia
against ukraine
this is also worn our energy
it's a war on our economy
it's a war on our values
it is a war on our future
it is about autocracy
against democracy
and i stand here with a conviction
that with the necessary courage
and with the necessary solidarity putin
will fail and ukraine and europe will
prevail
well our correspondent alexander von
neumann followed that speech in
strasbourg and gave us her thoughts
well i think we have to say that this
speech that we heard today was totally
different from the one that we heard
here last year when the mood was more
optimistic with the covet 19
restrictions being eased with the
vaccination drive in full swing and the
economy growing again now the european
union has to deal with the brutal war on
its doorsteps and it's facing a severe
energy crisis so those are the
challenges that ozola fonda lion
addressed in her speech that speech
however still was a message sending a
message of solidarity and courage as we
just heard because she was trying to
convince
her audience that europe can prevail as
long as the european union and their
member states are standing
together
and the the war in ukraine has prompted
changes in all sorts of ways across the
block amongst which
uh on the line has talked about an
electricity market reform let's just
listen
in these times it is wrong to receive
extraordinary record revenues and
profits
benefiting from war and on the back of
our consumers
in these times
profits must be shared
and channeled to those who need it most
[Applause]
profits must be shared and channeled to
those who need it most how how united is
europe in terms of energy policy
alexandra
well when we talked specifically about
this one proposal to put kind of tax or
levy on windfall profits of companies
they that do produce electricity at a
lower price but are still profiting from
the soaring gas prices that is something
that i think member states can agree on
that those companies
have to to sort of pay a price for that
that there should be a kind of tax on
their profits that could be then
channeled to ordinary consumers whose
bills are exploding at the moment and i
think
this is a major concern for all member
states however when we continue to speak
about other measures that are being
discussed right now like for instance a
cap on gas prices or gas imports from
russia that is something that is being
discussed very controversially and we
have to say that on that topic not all
member states are on board right so and
just to pick up on that point the the
commission president
can outline these proposals but they
still need to be signed off by
individual states she can't say this is
what we want and it's done
well i guess she would love to but
you're totally rightful the member
states have to sign off on that they
requested the european commission and
other la von de la and to put forward
those proposals and we are certainly
going to hear more detail later today
details later today on that but member
states all 27 of them still have to
approve
those measures and that might be a
reason a bit for us on the lion not to
be very specific very concrete in her
speech for instance on the topic on
price caps because of course she's aware
of the fact that it is up to the member
states to decide and that this one
measure could be very controversial
among the member states
and how effective has the commission
been so far in addressing
the energy concerns of the 27 member
countries
well i think we can say that they have
been doing quite a good job so far even
though as i said the latest measures
were not
as concrete as some member states would
like them to be however they have come
forward for instance with this proposal
for joint procurement of
energy for all member states that is
something that is gaining some speed and
that could help the european union to be
a
even a more important player on the
energy market because with all the 27
member states it is a sort of force to
be reckoned with if they're all buying
together there are some uh member states
that are critical or
a bit uh
opposing uh that but overall all i think
we can say that
they have been doing quite a good job
still of course uh now they need to
propose
those measures in a more concrete terms
that is something that the member states
are waiting for okay thank you for that
uh alexander alexandra von nerman in
strasbourg
well an eu cap on energy company profits
could free up as much as 140 billion
euros to cushion the blow of soaring
inflation that's likely to be welcome
news to many households who fear cold
and poverty as a result of rising energy
prices christine mundoa reports from
belgium
the forecast is for a difficult winter
in europe
but even before the cold season arrives
households across the eu
are already feeling it bite
belgium has one of the highest energy
inflation rates in the european union
and the federal government here is in
talks and negotiations with the banks to
try to bring relief to some of the
hardest hit households by deferring
mortgage payments for example
but households here have been told that
they need to brace for what will be
likely several years of difficult
winters ahead
for this family it is the winter that is
only weeks away that's causing the most
anxiety
they are already cutting back on how
much energy they use
we already replaced all the lamps for
led and at night we're almost using this
lamp
the race is most of the the most of the
house is dark we are doing the the
dishwash and we are using the wash
machine only at night
because the price of the energy is lower
so
during the day even in the weekends we
don't use
these machines during the day only at
night everything is more expensive the
fuel the transport
the supermarket the groceries are more
expensive with the bills piling up as
the cost of living soars
taxpayers in the eu are looking to their
governments for help
and indeed some eu countries have
announced plans to offer relief to their
populations
at their last meeting energy and economy
ministers agreed on where some of the
money to pay for this help would come
from
the current idea is actually to
introduce kind of a profit cap to say
okay there are certain companies
especially in the electricity field that
make a lot of profit because the prices
are so high although their costs are
very low
so that one says we introduce a kind of
a tax any profit that's above this will
go to the government which gives the
government and the resources to
subsidize certain households but it is
russia's gas many eu countries rely on
to keep the heating and lights on
and as tensions escalate between
brussels and moscow over the war in
ukraine
it is feared russia will completely cut
off its gas supply
plunging millions into freezing darkness
and europe's economies
into recession
you